Every girl wakes up knowing that someday,
death's sweet embrace will come for her.
And we hope that he'll look like a
well-oiled muscle machine.
But if not, maybe a cat on a unicorn.
You'll wanna spend a majority of your life
fearing growing older, and adamantly
fighting it with anti-aging serums,
cosmetic enhancements,
and healthy eating and exercise.
Make sure you're driven by the
fear of becoming unfuckable
and fading into irrelevant obscurity.
Frantically try to find a partner in life so you can
avoid the fearsome nursing homes and solitude
and old age that you witness being shoved under
the rug in society.
Eventually,
you'll have periods of rest.
Where you fully believe that you are invincible,
immortal, and that death happens to everyone else.
But not you.
(dramatic music)
Then, just as quickly,
you'll realize that everything is meaningless,
since our lives are nothing but a blink of an eye
in the universe, and you'll be fueled with the
desire to make your mark on the world
and fulfill a purpose or destiny.
This is often workaholicism.
As you get older, perhaps you'll see death,
riding on by on his cat-controlled unicorn,
winking and waving and whispering,
"You're next."
These encounters will simultaneously
calm and scare you shitless.
You will spend so many nights in an existential crisis,
questioning everything and receiving no answers..
The best course of action here is to just accept
the inevitable darkness that consumes us all.
(light music)
The best way any girl can get ready for death
is not necessarily to live like
life is short, because it's not,
but you also don't wanna err on the side of being
overly cautious, and regret not taking risks.
The happy medium is between the two.
Not being afraid of the trivial, like
confessing your love to someone,
but being cautious in a good way,
such as cutting out people in your life
who don't truly care for you.
Though death should be kept somewhere in the back
of your mind as a little reminder to cherish
what and who you have now,
don't let it be a force of fear.
All bad things, all good things,
all things,
come to an end.
So have some fun.
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara